i saw you allude that you you have an
unreleased juice world song yeah i do
yeah um you obviously i remember when
that tour happened yeah it was like
super early on super early on now i feel
like you didn't even i don't even know
if the ybn mixtape was out yet no it
wasn't it sure wasn't it was like like
all i had was three songs
short and two of them was damn
freestyles you know yeah and um out that
whole set was unreleased but man that
was like it's some real historical [ __ ]
because just looking just at my what
i've done or
just that's something i'm always going
to be able to tell my kids like my my
first time ever touring was on i was
throwing with juice world and juice this
is his first tour too so this is both of
our first time kids first like tour
being that [ __ ] like no that was
his first tour ever yeah it happened
fast for him for sure yeah that was his
first tour ever was clever on that tour
no he wasn't clever it was me juice
world and little mosey wow and um
i just be looking back even at like the
marquis like juice world
corde under it you know what i'm saying
and um
so i say that to say uh yeah we we do we
definitely got to unrelease that a song
that you are interested in even
releasing or um in the future probably
you know i never wanted like when he
came out it wasn't like man i got to put
the funny enough man our last text
between each other was like about the
song you know
and um i say all that to say that you
know when he passed it wasn't like it's
not something i want to capitalize on
and drop this record because i know it's
going to be it's going to go up
yeah yeah
one is a great song by the way two
um it's on some rap [ __ ] but i never
wanted to like
capitalize off a friend's death so if it
never comes out like
i'm cool with that he's rapping on it
yeah he's rapping like i'm trying to
tell people like juice world was like
one of the nicest mcs
ill like crazy like he chose to be like
a [ __ ] do the melodies make super
hits like golly like not male 1 off the
dome we'd be like i remember when he
came in freestyle for me and head i was
just like floored i was like jesus
christ like this guy's you got to tell
him to stop he's a savant you got to
tell him to stop because you're just
going to keep going but
like i said this is something that's
more so like for my memories and for the
archives and you know
god willing if you know
um
obviously when it comes to postmas
releasing music whenever um that time
comes so why did you say that that word
right because i don't know how to say it
every time i read it i don't know if i
said it correctly possible
yeah i don't know how to i honestly
might have mispronounced it who knows
yeah the comments will let us we'll
we'll find out later but yeah it's never
something i want to be like i'ma just
release this it might come out years
from now i might not ever come out you
know i'm just always it's something
that's just sacred to me more than
anything more than jonah just you know
capitalize off a friend